Intuition is often an underrated - yet essential -  tool you can use when you're dating,
- escaping danger, or even to build your career.
The International Association of Administrative Professionals and Office Team
- surveyed 3,500 administrative workers
- and 1,300 senior managers,
- and discovered that 88% of them make decisions based on their gut feelings.
It turns out intuition is more than just magic when it makes up a good chunk of our life choices.
Are you wondering what your intuitive power is? There are five types of intuition:
Analytical, Observant, Questioning, Empathetic and Adaptive.
Analytical intuition involves spending a lot of time researching
- and gathering data before making a decision.
People who identify as Analysts prefer to explore every potential scenario
- and want to understand all the details before a judgment is made.
They like to take their time and are the most thorough and precise.
Therefore haste, impulse, and recklessness are commonly avoided by them.
Lawyers, for instance, are specifically trained to rely on their analytical intuition
- when they focus on facts and objectifies to solve cases.
Next, we have Observant intuition, which involves gathering clues about people and scenarios.
People who identify as observers are often visual learners
- and pick up on physical cues in their immediate surroundings.
They are experts at finding visual patterns and notice subtle differences in their environment,
- such as a co-worker not returning their smile or when an object goes missing.
Observers tend to excel in outdoors-y and hands-on activities such as gardening
- or visual thinking careers such as art, web development and graphic design.
Then, there is Questioning intuition, which involves making judgments based on real-life evidence.
People who identify as questioners would rather rely on asking or surveying others directly
- instead of looking up online statistics before making a decision.
For example: Before releasing a new video, Questioners would rather directly ask
- their community viewers what they want to see next instead of searching what's trending or popular today.
People with Questioning intuition can make excellent investigators, accountants, and financial examinors.
Then, we have Empathetic intuition, which involves great listening skills
- to understand where the source of the problem lies.
People who identify as Empathizers withhold judgment and allow their colleagues and clients to vent.
This helps them figure out what works best in their favor before making a decision.
They usually work well in teams and are cooperative, considerate and introspective.
People with Empathetic intuition make natural psychologists, doctors, writers and counsellors.
And finally, there is Adaptive intuition, which is the most common form of intuition represented to the public.
Adaptive intuition is based solely on gut feelings and is used by others to help them think and react quickly
- in situations that require immediate action.
Adapters are great at giving advice and make reliable workers
- because you know you can always turn to them when you're in trouble.
They seem to always have a hunch on just about everything.
We hope that this video helps you discover more exciting things about yourself.
Which type of intuition do you identify most with?
Share your thoughts with us below to learn more about intuition.
Be sure to check out our video "7 Things Highly Intuitive People Do Differently".
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from Psych2Go and check out our Patreon.
Thanks for watching!